hey everybody we are back with the
marketing manager of eat and run
uh so we got to go over this again eat
and run
it's an app that does what now
well what our developers have done is
designed a data-driven dynamic dining
discovery and delivery service
specializing in serving
specifically customers and clients
currently
doing cardio our primary purpose is to
pair people with the perfect place to
provide them a quick bite
day or night before they're done with
the run all from the cloud
ah okay okay i see so your app delivers
food to runners
yeah exactly but from the cloud
okay so that interview has 1.8 million
views
now traffic is going through the roof
i'm prouder than
ever to have started this together but
all this attention
is also going to mean some challenges
for our technology right
yeah that's good and now more people
around the world can grab food while
jogging
walking or marathon training in these
uncertain times
we should definitely make sure our
infrastructure can handle the surge of
traffic
sure sure everything will be fine we
always planned for scale walk then
run and meet and run right
yes of course we did at totally big
scale
uh i see so maybe we're not as ready as
i thought
well for the good of the company for the
go to the people of the world their
ability to satisfy cravings
on the go we have to figure out a way to
scale
up don't worry we're running on the most
scalable
cloud architecture in the world and i'm
sure that we have the capacity to handle
any traffic spikes they deal with
enormous denial of service attacks
before breakfast
breakfast yes okay but let's do some
research
huh uh this article on the
internet has suggested some changes that
i think we can make
okay one option is load balancers and
managed instance groups
with all this traffic we could deploy
load balancers to distribute load more
efficiently across our front-end servers
then on top of that we set up managed
instance groups for our virtual machine
so each group can scale up or resize
based on demand
and option two looks like cloud cdn we
could speed up the delivery of our
assets to our clients with a content
delivery network
and added caching looks like using cloud
cdn helps us put the static assets
closer to those who need them
reducing the need for those requests to
hit our compute back ends
then we can add caching for static
content stored on the cdn
so our signup page for new eaters and
runners would probably load faster
it's up to you what should we prioritize
for the engineering team first since we
only have limited time and resources to
handle this
big traffic spike option one load
balancers manage instance groups to
scale up our back end serving
option two content delivery network and
caching to speed up our asset delivery
so what would be
you